- Just grinding like an operator.
We need to do something with
the operator thing, like a surgeon.
I like that.
(upbeat bass music)
(light electronic music)
- Where it gets really
interesting is culture.
Culture is the hidden retention of it all.
It's been really fascinating for me
to watch people, and it makes sense,
pick happiness over finance.
Even in their 20's, or maybe
especially in their 20's.
Literally the conversation
I was just having outside.
We've gone through a heavy,
kind of a very entry-level model.
We are building almost like a dumbbell,
going very heavy up top,
going incredibly systematic at the bottom,
and being very scrutinizing our middle,
where there's a enormous hidden garbage.
Be at the mercy of the individual
instead of creating, Vince
McMahon did it right, right?
He's gonna bring you
in, he's gonna name you,
he now owns that name.
You're not Brutus the Barber Beefcake.
You're not Hillbilly Jim.
And then, Babble will tell you up,
that's kind of what I've done for my team.
I've built such a brand that it's hard.
I like them, they're
good, there's continuity.
But it's hard for me.
It's a little hard cause I'm
a human, it's a small team.
But as a business model,
it's what I want to replicate
because I don't know,
there's 1000 people lined up
willing to work for free.
- If we change the laces.
I think there might be
regular laces in there.
- Yeah.
- This is, the box looks great.
- Yeah, it's going to be really fun.
How are you?
- I'm excellent.
- Great man.
What's been going on?
- Just trying to get the year in here.
- How's it ending?
No, I feel like I'm talking
to Brandon or my brother.
- Yeah, no, no.
- Listen, but that's why I'm
thinking about every variable.
So I'm thinking, okay, there's the,
you know, to your point,
there's something I've,
You've gotten to know me a little bit.
The thing that I'm worried about is,
I sabotage relationships
because I give so much.
I do the wrong thing.
I do the right thing so
much that I get upset
and then I do the wrong thing.
Scarcity versus volume.
All it is is a supply
and demand game, right?
So let's talk about this.
When does the 003 come out?
Okay, make some note,
well, somebody, yeah,
you make some notes.
- (Gary) What up vlog?
Dealing a little bit of a
fire right now with a client.
I'm gonna call in two minutes,
just had my K-Swiss 2018 meeting.
Had another meeting about some possible
business partnerships.
Heading to the LA office now,
a bunch of meetings there.
Then heading to airport,
heading to London,
for the holiday party and
some business meetings there.
Just a little LA, London combo
here to wrap up the year.
And here with my main man
Babbin, and that's it.
And when you say connecting,
I'll fucking fly in and fly out
to have a breakfast, lunch, and dinner
because, again, I need
you guys to know this.
This is more about how I
feel about myself as a man,
than about the size of the
financial vulnerability.
- I'm sorry--
- It's a pleasure.
- You're busy.
- How are you?
- Good.
- Good to see you.
- Thank you, I have
operations associates out.
- It's a pleasure.
- Great to meet you.
- (Gary) I love the Eagles gear.
(woman laughing)
- (Woman) Thanks.
- (Gary) Sorry about Carson.
- (Woman) I know, it's horrible.
- (Gary) Hey guys, happy holidays.
- (Many) Hey Gary.
Hey guys.
- (Woman) Hey.
Hi. Hi.
Hi Lauren.
- How are you?
- (Gary) How are you?
- Good to see you.
- (Gary) Good to see you.
- Just coming in?
- Just coming in.
- How was your flight?
- (Man) It was good, it was
last night, pretty good.
- (Gary) What up Instagram?
I wanted to jump on and
say, "Hey, hey, hey."
(clearing throat)
My voice is a little suspect.
I keep losing it, ignoring this cold.
Good to see you.
What up?
People throwing up the five, I like that.
Broden Bird, good to see you.
Trinidad James, the man.
Thank you Trinidad James.
Headed to London right
now, in the LA office.
Real good, got a lot done.
Just grinding, like an operator.
I feel like I'm an op,
we need to do something
with the operator thing,
like a surgeon, I like that.
Good to see you.
Happy holidays to everybody.
I see a lot of you getting your thing.
I just posted this video for a lot of you,
that you need to see.
- (Gary) and what you want, very easily.
You can go and play lacrosse in college.
You can try out for major
league lacrosse teams.
You can either succeed or fail,
but I got good news for you.
When you're 27, which is
a ridiculous young man,
you can just go get a job.
- (Man) That's true, you can go get a job,
but you can never go back, bro.
You can never go back to 21 years old
and take that leap of faith.
You're so young, but like plan.
But just do it, bro, fuck that.
(chattering)
- (Female) And ladies and gentlemen,
if you're standing by for Washington,
our next departure will
leave at two o'clock.
It should be leaving out of C41,
so if you wanna get over
to C41 and remain seated,
we'll hopefully be able to help you
(ding)
a little later with those seats.
(people chattering)
(ding)
(mellow music)